bonjour merci d'être avec nous en direct
sur rt france alors le premier ministre
libanais ou vient de le voir a choisi la
france pour sa première visite
officielle à l'étranger comment est
perçu 1 par les libanais ce premier
voyage diplomatique
écoutez je suis désolé je souris parce
que les déclarations étaient étaient au
bord de comics de que qu'on fait le
président maquereau et le premier
ministre nagib mikati maintenant je sais
pas comment les libanais perçoivent je
vais pas parler au nom des libanais mais
je sais que
aujourd'hui ils sont dans une situation
suffisamment catastrophique pour ne pas
je crois apporter beaucoup d'importance
à ces événements qui sont en train de se
passer il y a une chose qui est claire
mais généralement je commence à
commenter d'un point de vue libanais
mais mais là aujourd'hui il est clair
que la france pense avoir marqué des
points après avoir depuis 2000 18 tentés
de remettre sur selle le système
confessionnel à travers les accords de
cèdre qui se passait quelques semaines
avant
les élections législatives
aujourd'hui dans le cadre d'un accord
régional
elle n'a réussi à mettre au moins un
pion de plus au moyen-orient bien sûr
avec l'accord de l'iran des etats-unis
et c'est donc donc voilà alors pour
rigoler après ce que vous avez entendu
on va à contextualiser le premier
ministre libanais était donc un déjeuner
de travail à paris avec emmanuel macron
emmanuel macron qui s'est félicité
finalement que le liban se dote enfin le
gouvernement a demandé des réformes en
plus vite najib mikati se dit disposée à
mener ces réformes ne me cite un dans
les plus proches délais finalement vous
n'accorder aucune valeur à ces propos
on va pouvoir remettre un peu dans le
contexte pour que comme vous dites pour
que les gens sachent déjà il ya un terme
qui a utilisé par un bar emmanuel macron
qui est il a parlé de feuille de route
d'accord il en parle depuis un bout de
temps cette feuille de route personne
n'était au courant de ce qu'elle
contient ça c'est la première chose et
on est tellement pas au courant de ce
qu'elle contient que le que le nouveau
gouvernement dans sa déclaration de
politique générale à a dit que nous
allons implémenter les politiques que
tout le monde d'aujourd'hui connaît nous
allons implémenter les répudier réforme
desquelles tout le monde est au courant
alors bon je ne sais pas de quoi il
parle personne est au courant de ces
choses là dans ce contexte là nous
sommes encore bon je peux je pense que
nous allons en parler mais nous sommes
encore loin
aujourd'hui ce qui s'est passé ne répond
pas aux aspirations des libanais
pourquoi quels sont selon vous
aujourd'hui les aspirations des libanais
écoutez les aujourd'hui des aspirations
des libanais sont les suivantes nous
sommes nous sommes dans une situation où
le pays est en faillite nous n'entrons
pas dans une crise économique nous
sommes dans l'effondrement économique
ce pays est sur le point d'être liquidé
sa société est sur le point d'être
liquidée je vais vous donner quelques
chiffres nous avons à peu près 6000
demandes de passeports journalières au
liban d'accord depuis juin ça fait à peu
près 250 300 milles passeport qui ont
été demandés dans un pays dans lequel il
ya à peu près 4 millions de citoyens qui
sont résidents eh bien nous sommes en
train de parler d'un peu moins de 10% de
la population
nous sommes en train d'aller très
rapidement vers
quelques un demi million à un million de
libanais qui seront expatriés et qui
ceux qui se retrouveront en europe dans
le golfe et cetera parce que aujourd'hui
il n'existe plus dans ce pays ce qui est
nécessaire pour continuer monsieur
mikati qui n'est pas quelqu'un
nouveau venu sur la scène et qui n'est
pas un nouveau venu sur la scène
française non plus puisqu'il était le
partenaire de france telecom dans
l'opérateur ses listes dans les années
90 et 2000
a monté sa fortune à travers des
des deals qui se sont faits dans des
pays qui seraient considérés voyous ou
qui sont considérés voyous que par par
les pays européens et par l'occident en
général
et bien aujourd'hui il est venu
aujourd'hui pour
pour permettre à la france de mettre un
pied au liban moi je comprends
absolument que la france fasse ses
intérêts mais je ne pense pas sur le
long terme que sa face même les intérêts
de la france
aujourd'hui quel est votre plus grande
crainte finalement
ce que je viens de vous dire aujourd'hui
nous sommes face à une liquidation de la
société que les gens qui sont qui sont
au gouvernement le sachent le fasse cia
man ou patiemment la situation dans
laquelle nous sommes
va nous mener à une
liquidation de la société à la perte de
20 à 25% de des forces vives de ce pays
c'est à dire les gens qui
qui ont fait des études qui ont des
capacités qui peuvent produire il ne
restera dans ce pays et que les que les
gens qui ne peuvent pas partir qui sont
sujets qui sont trop démuni pour partir
et puis aussi
les réfugiés qui resteront syriens
palestiniens
travailleurs étrangers sri lankais
égyptiens philippins nous nous dirigeons
vers une complète reconfiguration de la
région et au liban une complète
reconfiguration de la société il se peut
que la société
qui se formera sur meilleure que celle
ci mais il lui faudra quarante à
cinquante ans pour qu elle se forme donc
voilà ce à quoi vont à l'énormité du
challenge auquel nous faisons face
mounir boumahni merci à vous d'avoir et
en direct sur rt français d'avoir
répondu à nos questions je rappelle que
vous êtes un membre du parti libanais
citoyens et citoyennes dans un état
merci à vous